und dies vor der Situation dass die Lage
in unserem Land ernst ist was die Korona
Pandemie anbelangt und
dass die Belastung in den Krankenhäusern
auch teilweise an die Grenzen gerät wir
sehen das auch an der Tatsache dass
Patienten verlegt werden und
deshalb haben wir heute von einem Akt
der nationalen Solidarität gesprochen
damit wir sinkende Infektionszahlen
bekommen und unser Gesundheitssystem
eben nicht überlassen sondern entlasten
in diesem Zusammenhang
ist doch normal hier aufgeführt und sein
beschlusspapier was wir ihn schon
berichtet hatten bezüglich des
Krisenstabs und der im Ziele
30000000 Impfungen
angefangen zu rechnen vom 8. November
bis zum Jahresende und dafür eben auch
die notwendigen organisatorischen
Maßnahmen
der Impfstatus
nicht dauerhaft anerkannt werden können
als doppelt geimpft und damit
abgeschlossen geimpft sondern es wird ja
auch auf der Ebene der EU diskutiert das
nach 9 Monaten der die zweite Impfung
ihre Gültigkeit verliert was heißt das
Boostern das nachimpfen das
Auffrischungsimpfung ist ganz wichtig um
dann als vollständig geimpft zu gelten
aber natürlich werden Übergangszeiten so
sein dass jeder auch eine Chance hat
sein Impfstatus wieder zu erneuern
wir werden bundesweit einen Zugang zu
Einrichtungen und Veranstaltungen der
Kultur und Freizeitgestaltung
unabhängig von der insta Denton nur für
Dienste und Genesende ermöglichen es
kann ergänzend auch einen Test noch
einmal 2G + genannt gefordert werden die
Zweig Regeln der ist auch auf den
Einzelhandel ausgeweitet ausgenommen
sind die Geschäfte des täglichen Bedarf
er soll für alle privaten Zusammenkünfte
oder Kontakte dann eine strikte Grenze
geben wenn sich ein nicht geimpfte
Personen dabei befindet und zwar geht es
darum dann den eigenen Haushalt sowie
höchstens zwei Personen eines weiteren
Haushalts also überall wo nicht alle
Teilnehmer geimpft und genesen sind gilt
diese Grenze eigener Haushalt sowie
höchstens zwei weitere Personen Kinder
bis zur Vollendung des 14 Jahre sind
hiervon ausgenommen
haben uns ja lange mit überregional
Sportkultur und vergleichbaren
Großveranstaltungen beschäftigt
vielleicht können die Ländervertreter
dazu dann nachher etwas sagen spätestens
ab einer Inzidenz von mehr als 350
Neuinfektionen in sieben Tagen pro
100000 Einwohner werden Clubs und
Diskotheken in Innenräumen geschlossen
und
es ist dann auch so dass
wir
sagen dass dies jetzt rechtlich schon
möglich wäre aber es wird noch einmal
gemeinsam vereinbart in Kreisen mit
einer Inzidenz oberhalb von
350/350 Fällen pro 100.000 Einwohner und
sieben Tagen müssen alle Kontakte
reduziert werden und deshalb gilt für
private Feiern und Zusammenkünfte eine
Teilnehmer Grenze von 50 Personen also
geimpfte und genesene in Innenräumen und
200 Personen geimpfte und genesene im
Außenbereich für die die ungeimpfte
dabei sind hatte ich ja erst schon die
Maßgabe gesagt in Schulen gilt eine
Masken Pflicht eine strenge Kontrolle
der Regeln wird durchgesetzt und es geht
um die Weiterentwicklung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes das ist jetzt
eine gesetzgebungs Arbeit die dann bis
zum 15. Dezember ja auch die Regelungen
ersetzen kann oder erweitern kann die
jetzt einen Übergangszeitraum hatten
hierzu kann vielleicht auch noch mal von
Olaf Scholz etwas gesagt werden weil das
ja auch die Gesetzgebung der zukünftigen
Ampelkoalition anbelangt
wird bald noch was drauf hin dass alle
von uns genannten Maßnahmen quasi
Mindeststandard sind dabei Länder können
strenger vorgehen und wir haben uns noch
einmal zur Impfpflicht geäußert eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht soll im Deutschen
Bundestag diskutiert und entschieden
werden dazu bieten Bund und Länder den
Ethikrat sich bis Jahresende einer
Empfehlung zu erarbeiten und dann kann
diese allgemeine Impfpflicht könnte bei
sprechender Entscheidung greifen etwa ab
Februar 2022
so deine Expertengremium von
Wissenschaften und Wissenschaftlern
eingerichtet wir haben uns mit dem
Silvester und Neujahrstag beschäftigt
das würde ich auch Henrik wüst
überlassen und wir haben uns noch einmal
zu den Wirtschafts Hilfen verständigt
Überbrückungshilfe 4 die natürlich an
Sichteinschränkungen von großer
Bedeutung sind sie sehen an den
Beschlüssen dass wir verstanden haben
dass die Lage sehr ernst ist und dass
wir durch weitergehende Maßnahmen
zusätzlich zu den jetzt schon getroffene
Maßnahme im Infektionsschutzgesetz noch
einmal dass insbesondere auch in hoch
Inzidenz Gebieten handeln wollen um
wirklich die Arbeit die stündlich und
auch jetzt zu dieser Zeit wieder in den
Intensivstationen geleistet wird nicht
nur anzuerkennen sondern möglichst auch
weniger notwendig zu machen und dazu
muss die vierte Welle gebrochen werden
und das ist bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft wir haben im Augenblick eine
gewisse Beruhigung aber auf einem viel
zu hohen Niveau und deshalb waren diese
Maßnahmen notwendig heute zu beschließen
Vizekanzler
wir sind in einer sehr sehr schwierigen
Situationen wie alle wissen sie hat
etwas damit zu tun dass wir zwar sehr
sehr viele geimpfte Bürgern und Bürger
haben aber nicht genügend viele um mich
um sicherzustellen zu können das nicht
erneut sich an der Infektionswelle durch
das Land beginnt das ist die Situation
mit der wir konfrontiert sind und das
ist auch klar was wir als allererstes
erreichen müssen es müssen sich
diejenigen noch durch den sich impfen zu
lassen das bisher nicht gemacht haben
und das ist auch an dieser Stelle mein
ganz persönlicher Appell dass wir alle
überzeugen den Schritt jetzt zu gehen es
ist wirklich wichtig und wir wissen
jetzt endgültig dass es eine Konsequenz
hat dass ein großer Teil der Bürgern und
Bürger sich bisher nicht durchgerungen
hat sich impfen zu lassen und wenn sich
das jetzt ändern kann dann wäre das sehr
sehr wichtig für mich ist das auch etwas
das mit viel Emotionen verbunden ist
denn wir wissen doch was für
mit lagen auf den Intensivstationen
entstehen wie schwierig das ist für die
Arbeitskräfte dort für die Pflegekräfte
für die Ärztin und Ärzte mit der Lage
umzugehen damit umzugehen dass viele die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen dort
jetzt um ihr Leben Ringen und deshalb
müssen wir es schaffen dass wir die
Situation ändern und das hat noch mal
der Appel sich impfen zu lassen und für
uns alle gilt dass wir das ganz
ehrgeizige Vorhaben jetzt in den
Vordergrund stellen müssen viele
erstmalig zu impfen und viele die eine
Impfung bereits haben mit einer
zusätzlichen Schutzimpfung zu versehen
das Boostern ist jetzt eine der ganz
ganz großen Herausforderung darum der
Krisenstab den General bräuerleiten wird
darum aber auch das ehrgeizige Ziel wenn
es denn irgendwie erreichbar ist bis zu
30 Millionen Impfung alles zusammen zu
erreichen ist Weihnachten und die kurze
Zeit danach um zu erreichen dass dieser
Schutz auch tatsächlich eintritt und wer
die Welle brechen können das ist eine
große logistische raus man sieht es an
den Fragen und den Schwierigkeit die
überall entstehen wenn sie Ärzte und
Ärztinnen Impfstoff bestellen wenn
überall neue Impfzentren eingerichtet
werden die müssen jetzt laufen das muss
alles ineinandergreifen und genau das
haben wir uns vorgenommen wir wissen
dass es ein ehrgeiziges Ziel ist wenn
man die verschiedenen Impfung
zusammenrechnet die da seit unserer
letzten
MPK und seitdem Beschluss der STIKO dass
alle sich
Boostern lassen sollen dass alle eine
Auffrischungsimpfung bekommen sollen
seit dieser Zeit auf den Weg gebracht
haben aber diese Kampagne muss jetzt
auch zu Ende geführt werden und zwar mit
einem großen Ehrgeiz nicht irgendwann
sondern ganz ganz kurzer Zeit weil dass
das wichtigste Mittel ist dass wir haben
und daneben brauchen wir natürlich viele
viele der schon genannten sehr
weitreichenden Maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass die Infektion sich nicht
ausbreiten können die Beschränkung die
wir haben im Bereich von Gastronomie und
anderen Bereichen für Zusammenkünfte 2G
und 2G die Beschränkung im Handel mit
Zweig was jetzt neu ist glaube dass das
richtig und notwendig ist dass wir auch
im privaten Bereich Kontakt Beschränkung
festlegen die ihm sehr streng sind wenn
ungeimpfte Bürgern und Burger dabei sind
notwendigerweise weil das ja eine der
Ursachen desinfektions Geschehens ist
all die anderen Dinge sind genannt
worden ich glaube das ist wichtig ist
dass wir klar und präzise sind dass man
sich geeinigt hat und dass das dazu
beitragen kann dass wir jetzt eine
bessere Lage bekommen ich bin froh dass
der Deutsche Bundestag bereits mich auf
den Weg gemacht hat darüber zu beraten
eine einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
einzuführen für Einrichtung in dem
besonders schützenswerte Bürgerinnen und
Bürger da sind die diesen Schutz auch
verdient haben und wofür alles dafür tun
müssen Altenpflegeeinrichtung und
Krankenhäuser und dass wir eine offene
Abstimmung Bundestag haben werden über
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht der
Anschluss ist gegeben da glaube ich wird
es jetzt auch vorangehen und aus meiner
Sicht sollte es auch zu einer solchen
Entscheidung des Bundestages kommen ich
bin auch ziemlich sicher dass das der
Fall sein wird
neben dem Krisenstab der des Impfung
Boostern Begleit und dafür sorgt dass
alles gut funktioniert wollen wir uns
auch regelmäßig neu beraten lassen
deshalb ein Expertenrat von
Wissenschaften und Wissenschaftlern den
eingerichtet wird und der natürlich
nicht nur die Bundesregierung und
Bundestag sondern auch die
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten mit Rat und
Vorschlägen versehen soll aber es sollen
Vorschläge seien die gemeinsam
erarbeitet worden sind die diskutiert
worden sind nicht dass da 15
verschiedene nebeneinander stehen so
etwas muss wo man sich auseinandersetzen
kann und muss dass wir alles dafür tun
dass diese Situation besser wird das ist
das was hier gemeinsam dich alle
vorgenommen haben und ich bin froh dass
in dieser schwierigen Lage der
Schulterschluss funktioniert das die
Parteipolitik in den Hintergrund tritt
und die Gesundheit der Bürger und Bürger
in den Vordergrund des gemeinsam
politischen Bestreben ist so soll es die
nächste Zeit auch weiter sein es geht um
eine große nationale Anstrengung und es
geht um Solidarität
Herr Ministerpräsident wüst bitte
danke im Namen der Ministerpräsidenten
und Ministerpräsidenten der Länder
möchte ich mich an erster Stelle mal
ganz herzlich bei all denen bedanken die
mit ihrer Solidarität helfen dass wir
gut durch die Krise kommen und
gleichzeitig alle nicht geimpften
dringend aufrufen die impf Angebote
wahrzunehmen nicht erst irgendwann
vielleicht im neuen Jahr oder nach
Weihnachten sondern ich jetzt Zigaretten
damit leben unser Land ist weiterhin
einer schwierigen Lage fliegen auch
schwierige Wochen noch vor uns die
Infektionszahlen sind weiterhin hoch zu
hoch Ärzte Pflegekräfte sind am Limit
und arbeiten teilweise schon lange
darüber hinaus und wir haben mit Omicron
eine neue gefährliche Mutation im Land
und das nehmen wir sehr sehr ernst
die Ministerpräsidenten von Sachsen und
Baden-Württemberg haben heute
eindrücklich die Lage dargestellt die in
Teilen unseres Landes eben nicht nur
kritisch ist sondern dramatisch seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg hatten wir in
Deutschland keine vergleichbare
Situation im Gesundheitswesen die
brauchen deshalb einen Akt der
nationalen Solidarität was heißt erstens
wir müssen in den nächsten Wochen
konsequent Kontakte reduzieren nur so
kann diese vierte Welle gebrochen werden
und zweitens impfen impfen ist der Weg
raus aus dieser schwierigen Lage in der
Pandemien deshalb müssen sich alle
impfen lassen die sich impfen lassen
können es ist richtig und es ist wichtig
ist heute auch wirklich gut gewesen dass
wir schlendern mit dem Bund eine
gemeinsame Linie abgestimmt haben jetzt
gemeinsam konsequent handeln wir haben
heute ein umfangreiches Paket
beschlossen
umfangreiche Kontakt Beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte deutliche Reduktion der
Zuschauer bei überregionalen
Großveranstaltung es gilt auch für
Spiele der Fußball Bundesliga Clubs und
Diskotheken werden in vielen
Bundesländern geschlossen 2G Regeln
werden ausgeweitet über dieser Stelle
ausdrücklich betonen das sind
Mindeststandards im übrigen haben wir
auch noch mal das Feuerwerksverbot fürs
Jahresende aus dem letzten Jahr
wiederholt auch dass ein Mindeststandard
in den betroffenen Regionen in den
besonders stark betroffenen Regionen
gelten selbstverständlich deutlich
strengere Regeln gerade in den Hotspots
brauchen die Verantwortlichen zur
Pandemie Bekämpfung zusätzliche Optionen
das ist doch in den letzten Tagen von
vielen Kollegen und Kollegen deutlich
gemacht worden ist deshalb gut dass Herr
Scholz für die künftige Regierung für
die Mehrheit der Deutschen Bundestages
Sattelbreite nachzubessern assumption
Schutzgesetz des Bundes zu überarbeiten
das ist eben besonders wichtig für die
Länder mit besonders hohen
Infektionszahlen ist die Ziffer 14 in
dem Beschluss Papier indem der
Gesetzgeber gebeten wird das
Infektionsschutzgesetz und weitere
Regelungen zu ergänzen damit Länder und
Regionen mit einem besonders hohen
infektions geschehen weiterhin
angemessene zusätzliche Angebot
Maßnahmen zum Schutz der Bevölkerung zur
Verfügung haben und darüber hinaus wird
der Gesetzgeber gebeten die
Übergangsfristen für Schutzmaßnahmen im
Infektionsschutzgesetz die bis zum 25
bremberg aufgetreten sind über den 5.
Dezember in aus zu verlängern und es
wird gesetzlich klargestellt dass diese
Maßnahmen auch regional differenziert
angeordnet werden können das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für Regionen mit besonders
hohen Infektionszahlen ich bin dankbar
dass das möglich ist liebe Frau
Bundeskanzlerin zum Schluss möchte ich
die Gelegenheit nutzen Ihnen auch im
Namen der Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten
ganz herzlich zu danken die 16 Jahre
waren gespickt mit vielen Krisen sie
haben unser Land gut durch diese
teilweise schwierige Zeit geführt in der
Korona Krise stehen sie nach wie vor
dafür den Gesundheitsschutz zur obersten
Priorität zu machen und Jenseits alle
einzeln Fragen hat das einfach viele
Menschen leben in Deutschland gerettet
Deutschland ist in den bisherigen
gut anderthalb Jahren der Corona
Pandemie besser als andere Staaten
durchgekommen ist es ihr Verdienst
verehrte Frau Dr Merkel dass sie dabei
auch immer den Schulterschluss mit den
Ländern gesucht haben wir sind immer
dann besonders stark wenn alle
staatlichen Ebenen gemeinsam arbeiten
und zusammen vorankommen wollen und wir
setzen sehr darauf dass der Nachfolger
hierfür Kontinuität steht und die Länder
auch in Zukunft nicht nur dieser Frage
als Partner sieht will noch mal einmal
zum Abschluss oder Vermerk ihre Rede vom
18. März erinnern
ich darf zitieren seit der Deutschen
Einheit nein seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
gibt es keine Herausforderung an unser
Land mehr bei der es zu sehr auf unsere
gemeinsame auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches Handeln
ankommt was sie damals gesagt haben gilt
auch heute wir müssen alle Solidarität
zeigen deshalb noch einmal der Appell
reduzieren Sie Ihre Kontakte lassen sie
sich impfen bzw Boostern und tragen sie
durch Vorsicht dazu bei dass wir diese
vierte Welle brechen
Regierender Bürgermeister Müller bitte
dieser Winter könnte härter werden als
alles andere was wir bisher in der
Pandemie erlebt haben dann könnte härter
werden hier werden wir nicht weiter
entschlossen eingreifen und handeln wir
haben das in den letzten Monaten
bewiesen dass wir das können dass wir
eingreifen gerade auch in den letzten
Wochen haben viele Länder ja schon durch
die Maßnahmen die sie ergriffen haben
auch verhindern können dass die
Situation weiter eskaliert oder Sie
haben es sogar schon erreicht dass es
einen leichten Rückgang desinfektions
Geschehens gibt will auch betonen dass
auch auf der Bundesebene das passiert
ist und sehr viel natürlich darüber
gesprochen und berichtet dass die
Notlage aufgegeben wurde durch die
Entscheidung des Deutschen Bundestages
aber einhergehend damit waren weitere
massiver Möglichkeiten einzugreifen wenn
man alleine andechs.de an die 3G
Regelung am Arbeitsplatz denkt oder auch
die entsprechenden Homeoffice Regeln sie
sind mit beschlossen worden von der
Bundesebene und bieten weitere wichtige
Instrumente im Kampf gegen die Pandemie
auch für die Länder wir haben heute auch
wieder miteinander wichtige Maßnahmen
beschlossen die eben schon dargestellt
wurden und ich glaube das ist uns damit
auch gelingen kann dass ich die
Situation auf den Intensivstation nicht
weiter zuspitzt dann dass es ja nach wie
vor das Maß der Dinge den
Gesundheitsschutz sicherzustellen und
auch dafür zu sorgen dass unserem
Kliniken weiter leistungsfähig sind und
die schwerste erkranken gut versorgen
können
bin sehr froh dass einige Dinge die auch
in den Ländern auch bei uns in Berlin
schon eine Rolle spielen jetzt auch
bundesweit verabredet werden konnten wie
z.b. auch die Zweig Regel am
Einzelhandel keine einfache Situation
für die einzelhändlerin und
Einzelhändler das weiß ich die
Reaktionen sind auch entsprechend in
Berlin aber wir erleben ebend auch die
Reaktion der Kunden die sagen sie finden
es richtig und gut das so eingegriffen
wird und dass es solche Regeln gibt weil
sie sich sicherer fühlen weil sie merken
dass es schützt also insofern konnten
wir auch auf dieser Erfahrung jetzt gut
aufbauen auch andere Dinge Einschränkung
bei Veranstaltung z.b. oder überhaupt
das Umsetzen der Zweig Regel der
praktischen so gut wie allen
Lebensbereichen sind denke ich wichtige
Maßnahmen man muss es immer wieder sagen
dass es besonders wichtig ist auch auf
die ungeimpften ihr zu reagieren die
ungeimpften machen und mal den Großteil
der Infektionen und den schweren Fehler
auch aus
bedeutet das eine Gruppe die deutlich in
der Minderheit ist wir haben inzwischen
bundesweit eine über 70% die Impfquote
also es heißt dass eine Gruppe die
deutlich in der Minderheit ist eben die
ungeimpften für die deutliche Mehrheit
der Infektion verantwortlich ist und
darauf muss man reagieren
und ich finde es richtig dass wir
jenseits der Frage der partiellen oder
allgemeinen Impfpflicht jetzt auch
wirklich an einem Punkt sind wo das
spürbar ist dass wir darauf reagieren
dass die die die Mehrheit darstellen die
vernünftig sind die
verantwortungsbewusst Angebote
angenommen haben nämlich die geimpften
dass die Möglichkeiten haben die andere
nicht haben das spiegelt sich auch heute
in unseren Verabredung und in unseren
Beschlüssen wieder
letztendlich abschließend aber auch
sagen
alles was wir miteinander beschießen
löst nicht die Situation auf dass jeder
auch eigenverantwortlich handeln muss
jeder kann eigenverantwortlich handeln
von Institutionen angefangen gleich an
der Stelle auch mal wir sind weit
entfernt von einem wirklichen Lockdown
die haben Einschränkungen beschlossen
aber wir ermöglichen auch immer noch
Dinge aber wir möglichen Dinge wo ein
Mindeststandard formuliertes und jede
Institution für sich auch gucken kann
kann man nicht noch mehr machen im
Übrigen kann auch ein Fußballverein mit
seinen Fans Kontakt aufnehmen und sagen
wir
spielen mit deutlich reduzierter
Zuschauerzahl oder vielleicht auch ganz
ohne Zuschauer weil uns der
Infektionsschutz so wichtig ist das ist
nicht verboten für ein Fußballverein so
eine Initiative zu ergreifen
genauso wenig verboten wie auch für
andere Institution
mir begegnet in den letzten Tagen ist
auch immer wieder dass Menschen auf mich
zukommen sagen ihr beschließt da immer
weitere Einschränkung wie wird denn das
kontrolliert es wird doch nicht
funktionieren ohne Kontrolle muss
zugeben dass ich ein bisschen staune
über diese Diskussion weil es so gut wie
keinen Lebensbereich gibt in dem wir uns
bewegen wo wir uns nicht auf Grundlage
von Regeln bewegen die wir gelernt haben
von denen wir wissen dass sie uns
schützen uns und andere schützen wir
beachten Sie ohne dass sie lückenlos
kontrolliert werden wir alle halten an
einer roten Ampel und wir wissen das
nicht neben jeder Ampel ein Polizist
steht der kontrolliert ob wir anhalten
aber wir haben gelernt dass es uns und
andere schützt dass es sicherer ist an
einer roten Ampel zu halten
warum ist das eigentlich nicht so
selbstverständlich nach den letzten
anderthalb Jahren Corona Pandemie
möglich also insofern
sage ich ja die Politik bleibt in einer
Verantwortung Rahmenbedingung zu setzen
das ist unsere Aufgabe und wir kommen
dieser Aufgabe auch nach und wieländer
aber es kommt gerade vielleicht auch für
die nächsten Monate noch mal darauf an
bis wir einen noch deutlich höhere
Impfquote haben auch mit der
Durchsetzung der Impfpflicht es kommt
für die nächsten Monate auch noch mal
auf Eigenverantwortung an es gibt ganz
viele die so eigenverantwortlich schon
gehandelt haben in den letzten Monaten
und ich hoffe dass es auch in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten immer mehr
tun werden weil sie im wissen wie
wichtig ist für unser Zusammenleben in
einer Solidargemeinschaft ist genau auf
solche Regeln die uns und andere
schützen auch zu achten
danke zu ihren Fragen ich bitte um eine
Journalist angefangen mit Herrn Rinke
von Reuters
ich habe eine Frage an deinen Stolz und
zwar mit Blick darauf was zur gerade das
2G oder die zwei gegen Regelungen für
den Handel bedeutet es gibt ja schon
Berechnung dass das Milliarden Einbußen
Umsatzeinbußen beim Handel bedeuten ist
das jetzt eine auch finanzielle
Schleifspur für das was die Pandemie
Bekämpfung bedeutet können Sie dann
Umfang geben und nachdem er Müller das
gerade eben erwähnt hatte wie ist das
mit der Durchsetzung wie soll in Sachsen
wenn in einem Landkreis 50% nur geimpft
sind eine solche Regel durchgesetzt
werden glauben Sie dass das
realistisches oder wird das auf
Schwierigkeiten stoßen
diesmal gibt es ja mehrere Länder die
bereits Zweig im Handel eingeführt haben
da kann man von der Praxis lernen und
diese Praxis ist gut das gilt z.b. auch
hier in Berlin da kann es jeder vor Ort
mich anschauen das funktioniert aus
meiner Sicht sind wir in einer
besonderen Situation die meisten Bürgern
und Bürger haben sich impfen lassen das
dürfen wir ja immer nicht beiseite
lassen wenn wir über die gegenwärtige
Lage reden das ist anders als vor einem
ja das ist anders als vor dem letzten
Winter wo die Impfung ist im Aussicht
standen und noch gar nicht möglich waren
als wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt vor 1 Jahr
zusammen kam und deshalb ist es jetzt
auch vertretbar zu sagen es gibt diese
Zugangsbeschränkung bei dir jeder und
jede die Möglichkeit hat durch eine
eigene Impfung die Lage für sich zu
verändern und genügend Impfstoff zur
Verfügung steht und jeder das hätte
längst machen können was müssen wir
gleichzeitig im Blick haben dass die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen abgefedert
werden und genau das ist vorgesehen wir
haben sämtliche Wirtschaftshilfen alles
das was wir auf den Weg gebracht haben
in den letzten Jahren dass wir immer
weiterentwickelt haben dass wir immer
umfassende ausführliche ausgestaltet
haben verlängert und werden das wo es
noch nicht der Fall ist abschließend
auch noch mal tun sodass ich alle darauf
verlassen können und das ist glaube ich
die gute Grundlage dafür ja und
ansonsten gilt natürlich überall in
Deutschland impfen Ostern das ist der
Weg aus der Krise
Herr blank dpa
Bundeskanzlerin sind sie persönlich für
eine Impfpflicht und erlauben dir eine
ganz kurze zweite Frage was ein Tag des
Abschieds ist für sie heute letzte
Ministerpräsidenten Runde sind sie
erleichtert oder traurig und sehen Sie
die Corona Bekämpfung bei Herrn Scholz
jetzt in guten Händen danke
für aussprechen würde
also auch dafür stimmen wurde und ich
glaube
wir haben alle gehofft dass die
Freiwilligkeit hier besser angenommen
wird wir haben auch gehofft dass die
Variante Delta vielleicht nicht so
aggressiv ist sodass auch eine Immunität
der Gemeinschaft schon mit einer
geringeren Impfquote erreicht werden
könnte nicht spricht dafür dass wir das
jetzt noch schaffen können und deshalb
ist der Weg aus der Pandemie die Impfung
und deshalb muss man dann auch diesen
Entschluss Fällen so jedenfalls meine
Überzeugung ansonsten waren
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz and immer
Teil meiner politischen meines
politischen Tageskalender Soder meiner
politischen Agenda sie sind oft
herausfordernd gewesen und das ist auch
nicht verwunderlich denn der
Föderalismus ist eine große Stärke
Deutschlands aber er bedeutet eben auch
dass Verantwortung auf verschiedene
Ebenen verteilt ist und da gibt es halt
auch unterschiedliche politische
Überzeugung und dass wir da immer auch
jetzt in dieser großen Herausforderung
zu gehen müsst sie benannt hat zu
gemeinsamen Beschlüssen gekommen sind
dass es gut und das ist wichtig und ich
denke das wird Olaf Scholz genauso
Gelingen der hat ja noch den Vorteil
dass er aus der Länder Perspektive schon
mal gearbeitet hat da durfte ich ihn
auch kennenlernen er weiß also wie
ärgert sich Länder sind ihre Sichtweise
durchzusetzen aber der Bund hat ja auch
seine Interessen und die wird
unterstützt auch gut vertreten können